you know they put the you know the fake
head and everything i think that was a
faking or did he no no
day shift is a fresh take on classic
vampire mythology in this action-packed
horror comedy we've got insane practical
stunts beautiful chemistry between cast
and crew and an incredible hair and
makeup team to bring this jj perry film
to life
let's check this out number one there
were a ton of practical effects in this
film jj's taken some vampire mythology
and put it in crazy situations of
gunfights and car chases not only did
the actors spend hours in target
practice and have actual contortionists
on set but they also did real car and
motorcycle chases on the streets of
california and the stuff that you see is
amazing and it's practical number two
the vampire's movements were done by
actual contortionists jj perry revealed
on twitter that he didn't want to rely
solely on special effects for the
vampire fight scenes so
he hired a team of contortionists to
recreate the vampire's insanely flexible
moves one thing to take note of though
was that the actors had to be very
careful when putting hands on their
bodies we weren't allowed to jerk
or do anything
quick if they made the wrong move it
could be very bad for the contortionist
she sort of like i guess disengages her
body so it can be very vulnerable number
three we're coming in sharp carla souza
who plays the ice cold audrey san
fernando definitely had her fair share
of vampire strife on set it was so hard
with the fangs
jamie foxx couldn't keep a straight face
during a whole lot of their scenes
together because of her fang-induced
lisp as she is threatening his life no
less
it made it really hard for him not to
laugh i was like this and i was like
you're going to suffer i was so bad not
only did the fangs make it hard for her
to deliver her lines but
they were very pointy so i drew blood a
couple of times on my on my lips because
of it number four obviously one of the
things we love about this movie is just
how practical it is even the actors
wanted to do as many stunts as they
could
everyone trains
and it looks so good
something unfortunate about the movie is
that they didn't really have any
rehearsals as an entire cast because of
the covet precautions so stunt training
in atlanta was where they all got to
come together and connect as a team
looks so good when you see you guys move
and it's you and it's not like
some hidden devil number five this car
chase sequence was also shot super
quickly jj perry is not messing around
when it comes to his stunt crew i picked
the people that i knew were going to be
soldiers and that moved fast something
unique about the way this chase was shot
was the angle that came through the
sunroof of the vehicle the decision to
do this happened pretty organically at a
starbucks in culver city so if i was in
the backseat of a car with gloves on
could i throw the drone out of the car
if it checked up in a slide then he said
let's go try it number six because of
how many people had to step in for one
character
six different people are gonna be
playing one person that hair and makeup
chair was in constant rotation the stump
person the actor the contortionist not
only did they have to do the exact same
hair and makeup for six different people
but they had to do it in a way that
correctly shows what phase of their
vampiric transformation they were on
definitely not an easy task number seven
everyone loved having jamie foxx on set
something really creative and hilarious
that he would do was produce music based
on a specific line that was said in the
film it was like this is my valley
cabron drink him this was literally the
first day on set and he's like he goes
to the side and he's like this is my
valley
and he starts going off when carla souza
noticed what he was doing she started
putting in her own little touches
here i am like salsa dancing to like my
own song with my lyric that he just
created we are truly hoping they bless
our ears with this masterpiece sometime
soon let's just say they do number eight
unsurprisingly there was a ton of improv
in this film jj perry gave the actors a
lot of comedic freedom especially when
it came to the more conversational
scenes where they're just hanging out in
the car talking he told us from the
beginning he was like have fun do your
thing say whatever you want and so
you're like all right let's go
so every day jamie foxx and dave franco
were pretty much just trying to make
each other laugh during their scenes
together
more specifically the scene in the car
where they're talking about the twilight
films yeah that was all improv why do
you know so much about swelling
number nine this was one of dave
franco's most mentally challenging
scenes to film for the duration of the
scene his character seth is heavily
freaking out over all the vampires
attacking him also considering he's
known for now i just bit my favorite
it makes sense that his anxiety would be
pretty high it was so difficult for him
because of how long it took to shoot i'm
screaming at the top of my lungs and so
that's me as an actor five days being
totally pent up and it is exhausting
number ten it's not what you think
everybody pisses himself the first time
really yeah
that scene is actually way more
complicated than one would expect they
had to rig a tube into dave franco's
pants while a guy off screen pumped
liquid through it that's not even the
most awkward part of this whole thing
you needed to be in a place that's
believable where it would be coming out
of me
it took a handful of takes to get right
that's funny
number 11. the super sunny setting
that's actually pretty abnormal for a
vampire film jj perry moved to the
valley in 1990 after he got out of the
army i wanted to capture the same
feeling i had when i lived there so it
was that early 90s kind of rap song rap
music he utilized jamie foxx and snoop
dogg when it came to pick out the music
that perfectly captured the 90s vibe he
was going for because they're infinitely
better at that
in music and acting than i am number 12.
something almost satiric about the
vampires in this movie is their
difference in origin depending on what
type of vampire it was jaime fox's
character bud would distinguish the
value of their fangs
none of that genogram was actually in
the script we created that you know the
eastern vampire the southern vampire the
uber vampire apparently we have a lot
more to look forward to if we get a
chance to do another one i have a lot of
ideas i don't want to give it up now
number 13. big john is a force to be
reckoned with he's a top-tier vampire
hunter so of course he's gotta have a
top-tier weapon yeah i was like imagine
he's snooping a gun like that called big
bertha come on he doesn't wanna watch
that apparently it was also insanely
heavy hey
hey this thing went like a tongue
number 14. something that might seem
shocking about a movie this massive was
that it was shot during a global
pandemic in just 42 days there was no
room for mistakes so i prepared and
prepared and prepared there's no way
this would have gotten done in such a
short amount of time without jj perry
behind it his production designer was
completely in sync with his action team
who he's been on the road with for over
eight years go all over the world doing
these movies we can communicate with
looks we don't even talk we just go
number 15.
it seems like this movie really popped
off the screen
mainly because of how much chemistry
flowed naturally between the cast jamie
foxx and dave franco loved working
together not only because they got to
improv throughout the film's entirety
where i was like oh we're flying oh yeah
yeah cause we were ad living on it but
because they really encouraged each
other to be at their best and most
natural you don't even have to tell me
just do your thing i'll follow you
another thing to note is that jamie foxx
has always wanted to work with dave
franco he said he didn't want to do the
movie unless he was cast i've always
tracked day i've always been trying to
find him and a way to work with himself
dayshift has makeup artists trying to
make six people look exactly the same
actual contortionists rpv drones being
thrown out of a sunroof during a car
chase and a hilarious cast to tie it all
together what more could you ask for
what was your favorite moment to watch